Android 4.2 introduced need of support
for right to left layout mirroring.
There are two simple changes
that you will need to make.
In the Android manifest file,
add android:supportsRtl="true"
To the application element.
Then, in each of your app's layouts,
change all of the left/right layout
properties to the new
start end equivalents.
Note that if you're targeting SDK 17 or
higher you can replace each left/right
property with a start/end equivalent.
But, if you're supporting
an earlier SDK version
you'll need to use both versions.
For example,
you'd use both android:paddingLeft, and
android:paddingStart in each layout.
There are also a few new attributes
that let you have precise
control over LTR and RTL layouts, such
as text alignment and layout direction.
So check the documentation for
more information.